the canadian deputy prime minister
christia freeland is positively giddy
about her ability now to shut down the
bank accounts of these truckers freeze
their assets and take them from ordinary
working-class people who just don't want
to take a
experimental drug the fouchy algae to
potentially maybe but probably not stop
the infection that doesn't pose a
particularly grave danger to most people
she's going to shut down she's going to
take all of their assets that they've
worked for and she couldn't be happier
about it
so you're confirming that accounts have
been frozen both personal and corporate
but you're not releasing the information
and the actual follow-up is
i'm just wondering whether the bank
accounts will be targeted of individuals
who donated to the give sengo and the
gofundme campaigns are they considered
designated people under the emergencies
act meaning that their credit cards
could be cut and financial services are
targeting them as well
okay
so the names of both individuals and
entities
as well as crypto wallets
have been shared
by the rcmp
with financial institutions
and accounts have been frozen
and more accounts will be frozen
when she's answered this is the
follow-up to that question and you can
hear at the very beginning of that
follow-up
yo yes we have oh you know we have oh
yeah those truckers we've totally taken
their money uh-huh we're sharing it with
the financial institutions
you should maybe you shouldn't have
questioned the government maybe maybe
you shouldn't have protested
she's drunk with power
fouch is drunk with power trudeau is
drunk with power the ruling class in the
bureaucracy and in the elected
government they are drunk with power but
that's not the whole story
okay a lot of
leftists right now are saying you know
you conservatives you would have a very
different view of the trucker protest if
it were blm and antifa shutting down the
streets and to them i say
you're absolutely right did you like
that clip i hope you liked that clip if
you did leave me a comment just say hey
michael i you know i enjoyed that that
was nice i like your hair today that's a
lovely sweater you got to subscribe you
got to ring that bell get all the
notifications for the next videos and
maybe let's say you're not getting the
notifications for whatever reason
youtube head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts type in the
michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]